the juror experience
you were just mentioning what china's
doing to kind of uh regulate its
internet that's because you're worth
speaking about yeah have you been
following this yeah that's what
terrifies me is that we have to become
like china in order to deal with what
they're doing um i i i just i feel like
one step moving in that general
direction is a social credit score
system and i'm terrified of that and i
think that that is where vaccine
passports lead to i really do and i
think
this idea that they're slowly working
their way into our everyday lives and in
this sort of inexorable way where you
have to have some sort of paperwork or
some sort of a cue code or something on
your phone or qr code
that scares the [ __ ] out of me because
that that's you're never going to get
that back right once the government has
that kind of power and control
they're going to be able to exercise it
whenever they want with all sorts of
reasons to to institute it i'm worried
about that too but i will say also just
to also notice that everywhere there's a
way in which a small move in a direction
can be
shown to lead to another big boogeyman
and that boogeyman makes us angry social
media is upregulating the meaning of
everything to be its worst possible
conclusion so like a small move by the
government to do x might be seen as this
is the first step in this total thing
i'm not saying that they're not going to
go do that i'm worried about that too
but to also just notice the way that
social media amplifies that the degree
to which we all get kind of reactive and
triggered by that the thing i think is
worth mentioning is what china is doing
regarding
its internet
because it's
seeing real problems and we might not
like their solution we might want to
implement a solution that has more civil
liberties than we should let's explain
what they're doing yeah so i'll i'll do
it quickly so um
it's almost it's quite literally as if
xi jinping saw the social dilemma
because they've in the last two months
rolled out a bunch of sweeping reforms
that include things like
if you're under the age of 14 and you
use doing which is their version of tick
tock
when you swipe the videos instead of
getting like the influencer dancing
videos and soft pornography you get
science experiments you can do at home
museum exhibits and patriotism videos
wow so you're scrolling and you're
getting stuff that's educating because
they want their kids to grow up and want
to be astronauts and scientists yeah
they don't want them to grow up and be
influencers uh and i'm not when i say
this by the way i'm not just to be clear
i'm not praising that model just
noticing all the things that they're
doing well i'll praise it
i know that you gotta influence people
that's a great way to do it they also
limit it to um three hours uh sorry 40
minutes a day on tick tock for gaming
let me actually do the tech talk example
so they do 40 minutes a day for tick
tock they also when you scroll a few
times they actually do a mandatory five
second delay saying hey do you want to
get up and do something else
like because when people sit there
infinitely scroll even tim cook recently
said mindless scrolling which is
actually invented by my co-founder of
the center for humane technology
azeraskan he invented he was in the
social dilemmas the one invented that
infinite scroll thing
um chyna said hey we don't want people
mindlessly scrolling so after you scroll
a few videos it does a mandatory five
second like interlude they also have
opening hours and closing hours so from
10 p.m until six in the morning if
you're under 14
it's like it's closed meaning
one of the problems of social media for
teenagers is if i'm not on at one in the
morning but all my friends are on and
they're still commenting on my stuff i
feel the social pressure i'm gonna be
ostracized if i don't participate and if
your notifications are on your phone
keeps buzzing totally and even if
they're not on it's like oh but i wanna
see if they said something about my
thing and so um it's it's a it's a we
call a multi-polar trap if i don't
participate but the other guys are i'm
gonna lose out and facebook and these
companies they know that by the way even
netflix said their biggest competitor is
sleep so
one of the um because they're all
competing for attention
so when you do this mandatory thing
where you say we're going to close from
10 pm to 6 in the morning suddenly
everyone if you're in the same time zone
it's another important side effect
can't use it at the same time so these
are some examples for their military by
the way when you if you're a member of
the chinese
pla army um you you get a lockdown
smartphone it's like a light phone it's
like hyper lockdown you can't do
anything by contrast we know that russia
and china go into our
veterans groups on facebook and they
actually try to sow disinformation try
to radicalize veterans hey afghanistan
happened aren't you really pissed let me
show you 10 videos right and this is
like dosing people with more mental
health problems right so in in a bunch
of different ways we see specifically if
you want to drive civil war in a
meaningful way in the u.s take the
people who have real tactical capability
and radicalize them
and so target those groups in particular
and that's like that's
it makes sense why their military wants
to lock down the ability for external
influence of course right so while we're
you know spending all this money
building physical borders building walls
or you know spending 50 billion dollars
a year on the passport controls and the
department of homeland security and the
physical you know russia trying to try
to fly a plane into the united states
we've got patriot missiles to shoot it
down but when they try to fly an
information
like precision guided information bomb
we instead of responding with patriot
missiles we respond with here's a white
glove facebook algorithm that says which
zip code or facebook group would you
like to target
right so it changes the asymmetries
typically what made us power what made
the u.s powerful was the geographic
you know we have these huge oceans on
both sides it gives us a unique you know
place in the world when you move to the
digital world it erases that geographic
asymmetry of power so this is a imminent
national security threat this is not
just like hey social media is adding
some subtle pollution in the form of
mental health or hey it's adding a
little bit of polarization but we can
still get things done it's an imminent
national security threat to our
continuity of our model of governance
which we want to keep spoken to people
in power have you spoken to congress
people
about this yes but i'm hoping many more
of them watch this because i think
people need to see the full scope and i
really do want to make sure we're not
sounding like just full disaster porn
because we want to don't worry about
that go full disaster porn well it's
just better than not
it's not meant to scare people just to
get an appraisal of what is the
situation it's going to scare the
reality is going to scale
it should scare people because we we're
so far behind the eight ball there's a
really important point tristan was just
at that we actually need to double click
on which is
that democracies are more affected by
what's happening with social media than
authoritarian of course nations are and
for a number of reasons but do you want
to
well and we sort of hinted at it earlier
but when social media's business model
is showing each tribe their boogeyman
their extreme reality it forces a more
polarized political base which means to
get elected you have to say something
that's going to appeal to a base that's
more divided and in the facebook files
that francis haugen put out
they showed that when facebook changed
the way its ranking system worked
in 2018 to something called meaningful
social interactions i won't go in the
details they talked to political parties
in europe so here we are in 2018 they do
an interview with political parties in
poland and hungary and taiwan and india
and these political parties say facebook
we know you changed your ranking system
and facebook like smugly responds yeah
everyone has a conspiracy theory about
how we change our ranking system because
those stories go viral and they're like
no no we know that you changed how your
ranking system works because we used to
be able to publish here's a white paper
on our agriculture policy to deal with
like soil degradation and now when we
publish the white paper we get crickets
we don't get any response and we test it
and the only thing that we get traffic
and attention on is when we say negative
things about the other political parties
so and they say we know that's bad we
don't want to do that we don't want to
like run our campaign it's about saying
negative things about the other party
but when you change the algorithm that's
the only thing we can do to get
attention it shows how central the
algorithm is to everything else if i'm
tucker carlson or rachel maddow or
anybody who's a political personality
are they really um saying things just
for their tv audience are they also
appealing to the algorithm because most
more and more of their attention is
going to happen downstream in these
little clips that get filtered around so
they they also need to appeal to how the
algorithm is rewarding saying negative
things about the other party so what
that does is it means you elect a more
political like representative class
that's based on disagreeing with the
other side and being divided about the
other side which means that it throws a
gear into the rent the wrench into the
gears of democracy and means that
democracy stops delivering results in a
time where we have more crisis we have
more supply chain stuff and inflation
and all these other things to respond to
and instead of responding effectively
it's just division all the way down
you